supongamos que nos piden que le pongamos
nombre a esta molécula lo primero que
hacemos es numerar estos carbonos este
es el carbono 1 2
4 y observar que tenemos un doble enlace
en el carbono número 2 entonces el
nombre de esta molécula es 2 buteno wood
de no2 porque el doble enlace empieza en
el carbono número 2
wood porque tenemos 4 carbonos y el no
para denotar que tenemos un doble enlace
presente en esta molécula y bueno
también nos piden que le pongamos nombre
a esta otra molécula enumeramos los
carbonos 1 2 3
4 tenemos un doble enlace en el carbono
número 2 y entonces el nombre de esta
molécula es 2 butano
pero como podemos observar estas dos
moléculas tienen exactamente el mismo
nombre pero son moléculas diferentes y
la razón por la que estas dos moléculas
son moléculas distintas es porque no hay
rotación libre a lo largo de los enlaces
dobles ok si tienes un enlace simple
como estos la molécula puede tener toda
la rotación que quiera pero los enlaces
dobles no permiten la rotación y
entonces estas dos moléculas si son
moléculas distintas aunque estos enlaces
dobles no permiten que puedas rotar
esta molécula para convertirla en esta
otra entonces son isómeros y necesitamos
una forma de distinguir entre dos
isómeros una forma de hacer eso es
utilizar la nomenclatura systems ok
así es que vamos a empezar con esta
molécula podemos observar que tiene dos
grupos metilo y estos dos grupos metilo
del mismo lado del enlace doble y si
ponemos esta línea que siga la línea del
enlace doble podemos ver que estos dos
grupos metidos están del mismo lado de
la línea del enlace doble que ya esté y
somero le llamamos cis entonces por aquí
antes del 2 escribimos cis de
preferencia en itálica si es posible así
es que esta molécula es el y somero cis
2 buteno y ahora vamos con el otro y
somero nos fijamos en los grupos metilo
y estos grupos met y los están del lado
opuesto de la línea que marca el enlace
doble ok dibujamos aquí esta línea para
que sea más fácil ver si estos grupos
metilo se están del mismo lado o de
lados opuestos del doble enlace y como
estamos observando están de lados
opuestos y a eso le llamamos trans
cree entonces ponemos por aquí en
itálicas trans ok entonces tenemos por
aquí 62 buteno y trans 2 wood en que son
dos moléculas distintas con propiedades
diferentes en fin si vas a usar la
anotación si es trans lo que tienes que
hacer es buscar dos grupos funcionales
que sean idénticos y observar si están
del mismo lado del enlace doble o si
están en lados opuestos del enlace doble
así es que observemos estos dos y
sombreros y determinemos si son cis o
trans vamos a empezar de este lado
tenemos aquí el doble enlace y bueno
pues tenemos estos dos grupos de ti los
ponemos por aquí la raya del doble
enlace y podemos observar que los dos
grupos de tilos enlazados al doble
enlace se encuentran del mismo lado del
doble enlace entonces este es el y
somero
vamos con el siguiente por aquí lo que
tenemos son estos dos grupos de ti los
que están en lados opuestos del doble
enlace entonces este es el y somero
trans bueno vamos a hacer más ejemplos y
para eso vamos a subir un poquito la
pantalla vamos a empezar por la
izquierda aquí tenemos una molécula de
cine maldecido y estamos buscando dos
grupos funcionales idénticos que estén
enlazados con este doble enlace entonces
lo observamos fijamente y nos damos
cuenta de que aquí tiene dos grupos
funcionales idénticos lo que podemos
utilizar los hidrógenos no tiene por qué
ser un grupo metil etil o cosas más
complicadas
coloque esta línea que es como una
extensión de este enlace doble para que
fuera más fácil observar que estos
hidrógenos están en lados opuestos del
doble enlace
creo que hay entonces este es un isómero
trans bueno ahora vamos con el siguiente
ejemplo que es un al que no te tras
sustituido y bueno estamos buscando dos
grupos funcionales enlazados con el
enlace doble para poder determinar si es
un isómero cis o temps
así es que pues aquí tenemos un grupo de
tilos y otro grupo de tilos un grupo
metilo y un grupo isopropílico ahora
estos dos grupos de tilos están del
mismo lado del enlace doble ok podemos
dibujar la recta
y como estos dos grupos de tilos están
del mismo lado del enlace doble entonces
este es un isómero cis ok
este enlace doble tiene una
configuración cis bueno y vamos a ver
más ejemplos
ahora vamos a comparar a estos dos
aunque la primera vez que ves a estas
dos estructuras de puntos puedes creer
que son isómeros y que puedes utilizar
la anotación systems para distinguir a
uno del otro pero resulta que no estas
dos estructuras de punto representan a
la misma molécula si tomas este dibujo
de aquí y lo volteas obtienes este otro
dibujo de acá cierto entonces éstos no
son isómeros son exactamente la misma
molécula y una forma muy fácil de darse
cuenta de eso es fijarse en este carbono
de aquí que tiene dos grupos funcionales
exactamente igualitos
entonces termina siendo la misma
molécula que cualquiera que podría
llegar a ser suizo pero ahora observa
que los dos grupos funcionales idénticos
están enlazados con el mismo carbono y
por lo tanto es completamente distinto
al ejemplo que vimos hace unos cuantos
minutos lo que donde tenemos aquí estos
dos grupos de tilos que son idénticos
pero están enlazados a dos carbonos
distintos aunque ya los dos carbonos del
enlace doble y entonces en esta molécula
si podemos utilizar la anotación systems
de hecho estos dos grupos idénticos
están del mismo lado del enlace doble y
por lo tanto es una molécula cis sin
embargo no podemos hacer eso con esta
molécula lo que no podemos utilizar la
notación systems con ella porque aunque
si tenemos dos grupos idénticos
dos están enlazados al mismo carbono